what happened yesterday
is that michael tracy the journalist
started a room
in when the title was approximately um
is clubhouse too obsessed with wokism or
something like that
um in any case uh
i went into this room quite late i think
the discussion was well underway
michael tracy was i believe
having difficulty moderating the room
a person came
onto the stage to speak and challenged
the fact that there were
by her accounting no people of color
with moderator privileges michael tracy
made her
a moderator i did not see that
interaction but that's what i've been
told and then a coup took place and
everybody in the room acknowledged
by the end of this discussion that it
was a coup so the person who had been
given moderator privileges
first kicked michael tracy out of the
off the stage then kicked all white
people off the stage
and the conversation radically shifted
um
and it you know so it was a takeover now
at one level who cares about some
takeover in some
ephemeral room on clubhouse on the other
hand
the nature of clubhouse is a discussion
and what took place in that room was
stunning not just to me
but to many people including peter
bogosian who was in the audience
and benjamin boyce now i would just
point out that uh peter begosian
benjamin boyce and myself are
three very well versed people when it
comes to
discussions of wokeness
racial interactions right it would be
hard to impress us
and yet all three of us were impressed
with what took place in this room it was
shocking impressed in a negative way
tremendously negative and my suspicion
is that most people have not heard a
conversation
like this one and so in any case
the um the nature of the
i think probably peter and benjamin and
i are going to have to
discuss what took place there in order
that people can get any real deep sense
of what it was but what was uh just
fascinating was the fact that although
in general there is a wide diversity of
opinions in
any clubhouse conversation above a few
people
the diversity of opinion dropped
to zero and what happened was
increasingly outlandish things were
asserted on the stage
with no objection from anybody which
spoke
to what i'm going to claim is a kind of
power
and one of the obvious results of this
will be that anyone who is on clubhouse
and paying attention to it
and who knows what you just described
a moderator who is chastised
who is asked to add someone else based
on a demographic
may well not do so in the future and so
legitimate inquiries about increasing
diversity that might be legitimate
although we can put aside for the moment
whether or not um
seeking diversity across demographic
features is going to maximize
cons conversation quality but that this
is likely to cause
exactly the opposite thing this is going
to
quite literally silo people um more
because
uh future conversations um by moderators
uh who have created a group around them
of people
who you know because it's who they know
looks somewhat like them in some regard
um if a woman says you need more women
you need a woman on the stage or a black
person says you need a black person on
the stage
those moderators now have legitimate
reason to be concerned that what is
happening is not good faith but it's
actually a coup attempt
so perfect you've just described the
birth of a kafka trap right you're now
damned if you do and damned if you don't
um and so that of course is a very
dangerous
dynamic right right one certainly wants
and in fact in general people have been
uh pretty generous with moderator
privileges and in general the rooms are
pretty well served by having
a fair number of people from different
perspectives have those privileges but
obviously if anybody can kick anyone
off the stage and you know i mean so the
idea is that any moderator has as
complete a set of privileges as any
other moderator regardless of whether or
not you set up the room or
just you know just added exactly um
and so this then goes to imminently
gamble
so gameable and um so i wanted to think
i wanted to think out loud a little bit
on the question
of what is power because what i saw
yesterday take place over i mean i was
in the room for
i don't know three plus hours what i saw
took place was a clear demonstration of
power and in fact the very first thing
that took place
in the immediate aftermath of this coup
i think i
shortchanged the story just a little bit
was
that a bunch of people on the stage and
it's very hard to tell when many people
are trying to speak at once who is
speaking
um it is relatively easy to tell when
one person is speaking at a time and
rooms differ as to whether or not people
talk over each other or wait their turn
but in this case
many people appeared to raise their
voice
um and uh try to prevent
this ushering of people off the stage
they wanted
a room in which there was room to
disagree
all of those people were eliminated so
what you had
was inside of i don't know maybe it was
30 seconds
you had a stage that was diverse
become at least at a racial
level become segregated so segregation
happened in this room
almost instantly and well but and you
know frankly more importantly at an
ideological level
exactly that's the thing is not only was
it racially segregated but it was
limited to those people who
were apparently and this became apparent
over
you know the course of hours were
apparently willing to sign on
to anything offered by anyone in the
room including
completely preposterous ideas i mean if
john mcorder or coleman hughes or thomas
chad and williams or chloe valderrie or
you know any number of
other uh you know smart black people had
shown up and said i'd like to come up on
the stage i don't think they would have
been welcomed
by by by your account of what it sounds
like was happening right
in fact uh john mcwhirter was
misportrayed
on the stage he was portrayed as a
conservative not surprising
but uh he was portrayed that way i was
brought up somebody noticed me in the
audience i was
brought up basically to be
cross-examined
you mean brought up to the stage or
mentioned okay i was brought up to the
stage and i was
asked if i was a white supremacist i was
asked
it's almost the four-year anniversary
why not play this game again well but
this is this is exactly it
and so uh whatever else we can say about
this environment
at one level this was a lot like the
ability
of somebody imagine a virtual i'm not a
fan of virtual reality i'm very
frightened about what it's going to do
to people's cognition
over time but imagine virtual reality
that would allow you
to teleport into the evergreen riots
with no physical
safety issue but the ability to be first
person
in that situation how much would that do
for people's understanding of whether
this was or wasn't an important event
whether it was or wasn't being
misrepresented right
that ability to just be present is
very persuasive and so
i i have the sense frankly that people
generally people on both the woke and
the anti-woke side
would have their viewpoint altered by
you know the ability to participate in
this conversation even just to sit in
the audience and hear it taking place in
front of them
would i think convince a great many
people that something important was
going on and many people i expect even
on the woke side would have the sense of
actually
i don't want any part of that right
because all of those claims
are i don't want to say all although
frankly virtually every claim
that was made was uh extraordinary okay
so what's to be done then
um yeah so this thing was ephemeral uh
and um you saw it firsthand it's
hardly the first time you've seen this
firsthand and so did benjamin boyce it's
not his first
time at the rodeo either peter pagosian
same thing you know
and i presume i know less about michael
tracy but i i
believe that he knows uh enough about
this to have
recognized at least in retrospect what
was happening um so
you know you were not further informed
um there you you think there would be
value
in people um in other people who did not
choose to be there
in hearing or reading um
this this thing that was ephemeral what
what then you know what does it mean or
what value can be derived from it
all right so uh for one thing
um let's just say peter was actually
tweeting about this
this morning about this conversation and
his point was the
constant refrain in this discussion or
at least the recurrent refrain
was that it all must be burned down that
this is effectively
that civilization oh civilization must
be burned
civilization is effectively white and
that whiteness
taints it beyond repair and it must be
burned down
now my point is for the vast majority of
people who have
had it right who have had it and may be
marching with blm
the discovery that there is at least a
a contingent wielding substantial power
whose viewpoint is actually our purpose
is to burn this down
and then things will be better because
they can't be worse
right that discovery the discovery that
a great many people who call themselves
abolitionists whether
they are talking about prisons or the
police or
generally both right that abolitionists
have taken that honorable term
and basically turned it on its head and
are think it's clever to uninvent
civilization
and that imagine that somehow that will
improve things that that would be a
wake-up call that would actually allow
us it would be the gateway to the actual
conversation
that we need to be having and so this
brings me back to the question of power
so loosely speaking i would say power
is the ability to reallocate or
redirect limited resources right
whether that is people's time whether it
is their attention whether it is money
right whether it is uh access to
a coveted spot in a school in a
uh an organization whatever it is the
ability to reallocate a limited resource
is power now my point is power
tremendous power is being wielded
by a movement that is composed of people
who actually have positions that cannot
be reconciled with each other
the burn it all down people are a
substantial contingent
but there are lots of people who would
not burn it down and know better than to
burn it down
who are wielding power together with
them and my point is
those two need to see each other right
and those of us on the outside
need to understand actually that the
movement
is these two unreconcilable things and
that means that we potentially have
partners inside that movement who we can
reach if they will
stop signing on to this reflexive
reaction in this conversation
uh the the coup on clubhouse um
i i i was asked to say something about
who i was before i was interrogated
about
whether i was a white supremacist and a
transphobe and there was one other thing
but i've forgotten what it was
fascist no sexist
no uh wasn't those things
right but um i said i was an
evolutionary biologist
oh that's just as bad which immediately
triggered one of the people
uh interrogating me to say oh you mean a
eugenicist
oh my god i know wow wow
now i once talked with an anthropologist
who seemed to complete those two things
just the same way
actually it's an amazing amazing thing
wow yep you know who was an evolutionary
biologist
huey p newton yes he was i find it
unlikely that he was eugenicist at least
not a white supremacist eugenicist
right i mean that just very little that
he did in his life would seem to support
that separation right
it's an extraordinary claim
you